new developments on the Republican push
for an investigation of alleged FISA
abuses by the FBI and DOJ in the Russia
probe the internal watchdog of the
Justice Department will examine
accusations of misconduct in the process
to obtain a warrant to surveil former
Trump campaign adviser Carter Paige
Inspector General Michael Horowitz's
investigation comes at the request of
Attorney General jeff Sessions and
congressional Republicans Judge
Napolitano thinks he will find
wrongdoing I believe that the Inspector
General will find a treasure trove not
just mccabe and company but that is the
most extreme violation we know of
because the target the victim is the
president the United States though he
was a candidate and then president-elect
at the time but he will find a treasure
trove of abuses going to FISA getting
warrants when the law did not justifies
the all right Kimberly so nobody has
actually read I think even Nunez
admitted congressman from California on
the Intel committee he hasn't actually
read the underlying documents that the
Michael Horowitz who's the inspector
general at the DOJ now says that he is
going to look into this as well he's got
a lot on his plate to investigate but
has the confidence of attorney general
sessions as well as members of the hill
on the Republican and Democratic side
tell me what you think are the most
critical issues that they should look at
yeah I mean I think you want to make
sure looking for in terms of who's
making the request what evidence they're
relying on to substantiate these claims
but we really have to give them the
opportunity to go through it because
otherwise the speculation in terms of
what kind of violations or you know
treasure trove etc that they might
uncover but I'm always interested in who
is Providence where they're getting it
from from what sources because we've
seen some of these abuses in the past in
terms of information that was proffered
that really wasn't accurate that wasn't
probative that wasn't verified so I
think that's important to check out in
terms of what they might be looking for
well we don't I don't think we don't
have a they're all looking into all of
those things there's a ton of
accusations a part of this Jesse comes
from the text messages between the two
FBI agents who are having an affair
right and they're going back and forth
and there's one of the allegations is
that there was coordination between the
White House and the FBI and then it
should have been more independent than
that this is during the Obama
administration right
not just the Obama White House but the
Obama White House the FBI the DOJ Harry
Reid the CIA and Hillary Clinton if you
just take it from the beginning Hillary
paid for the fake dossier filled with
Russian lies then you have a Hillary
donor who was the one that sent the FBI
the tip about Papadopoulos so these
Trump aiding FBI agents opened up the
counterintelligence investigation
then all of a sudden John Brennan the
CIA director under President Obama comes
along and briefs Harry Reid about the
dossier Harry Reid then turns around and
writes a letter to James Comey urging
him to open an investigation into the
Trump campaign at the same time the
Obama chief of staff at the White House
Denis McCulloch had been talking and had
been briefed by the counterintelligence
division of the FBI about the Trump
campaign investigation and from what we
believe he was urging it to move forward
so the briefing from Brennan to read was
then leaked and wound up in the Isikoff
article the Isikoff article was used as
a justification for the warrantless
spying on Carter page it's funny because
Carter page has never been charged with
a crime and was an FBI informant for
many many years so James Comey takes
this information and brings it to the
FISA Court judge it's all unverified and
unsubstantiated the dossier as we've
been over and uses the Isikoff article
as well and as this is all happening the
FBI agents text and they say here we go
so the allegation is that they have
through all of these people laid the
groundwork and laid the legitimacy for
the surveillance on the Trump campaign
so after Trump selected James Comey then
briefs the president on the salacious
dossier and that same day
CIA director under Obama Brennan leaks
the information to CNN so when all these
congressional investigators start asking
questions and asking for documentation
they get stonewalled by the FBI in the
DOJ I mean the coordination is amazing
if only Republicans could coordinate as
effectively as the Democrats it's one of
the things I think that Steve Bannon
said before he left was that
how we how could we collude we can't
actually fair point first imagine if
this kind of evidence was presented
under a president Hillary Clinton that
was against her undermining her the
media would be in their pink hats you
know making protest science out of
discarded Whole Foods Bad's but it's not
it's under Trump but I'm not gonna be
like them I'm not gonna get hysterical
over this this is to be one of the
longest dances I've ever seen in
politics I call it the collusion
two-step step 1 it's a Trump Russian
collusion step 2 no it's a coordination
among officials within the Trump Russia
probe and this two-step just keeps going
on and on it's the world's worst duel
it's like Hamilton for boring people so
I I know it's you're good at this I'm
terrible at this
I recommend we declare this beef a tie
and like you know in soccer where at the
end of the game is zero zero we can
settle this with penalty kicks this is a
zero-sum game it's like just have each
side do penalty kicks oh we should start
tree like the Russian diplomat thing we
should start expelling people on each
side news just came in that attorney
general sessions has stated that there
will be no special second counsel needed
now and that's based on review of the
materials from a federal prosecutor that
has been tasked with this for now it
doesn't mean that won't come later but
for the time being there won't be one
assign the other in addition to that
there was breaking news yesterday we had
the news that the New York Times broke
that the president's former lawyer John
Dowd had approached the lawyers for
Michael Flynn and Paul Manafort about
the possibility of a pardon and John
Dowd saying oh yeah that didn't really
happen but they have a lot of sources on
it and then the other thing is the other
story that just broke is that Reuters
says that there is additional
investigation Miller looking into the
actual conversations that were taking
place at the convention in Ohio for the
Republicans especially looking into how
that language about Ukraine got watered
down so much in the platform Wow so I
mean I just I mean all of this seems to
me to be striking because again you know
it puts the presidency in a very tenure
position if in fact you have John Dowd
no longer the president's top lawyer but
John Dowd reaching out to lawyers for
Paul Manafort and Mike Flynn to discuss
the possibility of pardons that's direct
obstruction of the muller investigation
because the idea in fact manna fort has
yet to strike a deal and people are
wondering what's going on there because
he's facing serious jail time
although kindness in RF one thing on
that point I did I was listening to the
daily this morning the podcast from the
New York Times and one of the things I
think was effectively said by if
somebody for John Dowd I think actually
was John Dowd he said what would we have
even pardoned them for you can't just
give Mike a blanket pardon for like use
it you're pardoned have to wait long
because guess what they're indicted so
you put an offer a pardon before you
know what they're going to know but you
can you can and then once they are
indicted say oh you know what no need to
cooperate no need to tell your tale that
might be damning to the president
because the president has the power to
pardon you but in this case although the
president's power is pretty much
unlimited with regard to pardons in this
case because he's the one under
investigation it would be illegal it
would be not necessarily legal I
shouldn't you say that it would allow
Robert Muller then to say there's an
obstruction of justice case based on the
behavior of the president's lawyers and
the second the second thing is with
regard to the Ukraine and the watering
down of the language at the convention
again here is Russia playing a role
potentially if this story is true Dana
that really again undermines the
democratic process that even Republicans
can't get their own policy platform in
place without Russia you can change a
policy that without you can't because
now the policy with regards to Ukraine
is much tougher than it was under
President Obama we've sold them missiles
and hard arms where Obama was giving
them food apps you forget that Russia
was upset that we were putting
anti-missile devices in Poland and other
places there the under the Obama
administration and then decided they
were going to take that aggressive
action and the Ukraine and again Obama's
ansel missile defense in Eastern Europe
was not as robust as george w bush's
I always want to make one last point is
this spice the thing is I think is total
distraction but guess what in January of
just this year you had a hundred and
ninety-one House Republicans and you had
43 of the I guess 52 Senate Republicans
vote to reauthorize and it's a very good
transition from my question to greg
which is i think there are some people
who are hoping for some sort of Ed
Snowden moment to if they're worried
about government interference and
privacy and Fourth Amendment things
hoping that a review by the Inspector
General about this specific case will
lead to some sort of wholesale review or
their elimination of the FISA Court
perhaps I don't know all I know is I
just see every single every single day
they have to find something new that
isn't working well no it is it goes I go
back to the golf bag of weaponry it's
like you have the iron of you know
stormy Daniels you have Russia you had
his physical health who had mental
instability every day there's something
and the language that is used in all of
these attacks against President Trump
use the phrase it suggests possible X
it's never it is it suggests possible X
so that when you talk about these fights
or things we can use the Republicans or
the Conservatives can say yes suggests
possible coordination so now the
anti-trump errs are feeling what they
have been doing all along to everybody
else using wishy-washy language clearly
though there is a group of people high
up in the corridors of power who are
figuring out a way to get rid of Trump
because they believe they had a higher
purpose that put them above the law and
they realized that you know what if they
don't do it it's them against the world
so they have to do it so they should be
willing to be punished for what they are
doing wrong because clearly they were
driven by some kind of irrational
emotional panic there's almost the exact
quote from a congressional staffer on
the Republicans really and I even read
the note this one who said we're not
saying anything actually was and
untoward here we're not saying anything
was improper we're just saying it should
be looked into and guess what now we'll
be looked into and we get to move on but
we think they'll be sorry you know the
thing is gigantic anymore cuz I
right the crazy this whole panic was
created by two two groups the anti-trump
media who didn't think their trump
obsession would get him elected and it
did and now they feel really guilty
about it and government officials who
became politically activated once this
happened that's what you're seeing right
now yeah maybe it's about Trump
president's refreshing breath of fresh
air Ron by maybe that's all right
irrationally